chaque décision comporte un enjeu et une
responsabilité et c'est pour cela qu'il
est si difficile de faire les bons choix
vous je dirais madame riz au premier
rang oui je vais vous demander dans un
instant de prendre une décision pour
l'ensemble du public ici présents vous
allez décider si je fais mon
intervention non j'ai ici une pièce de
monnaie
si vous trouvez dans quelles mains se
cache la pièce je poursuis mon
intervention
si vous ne trouvez pas la pièce je
quitte la scène vous avez une
responsabilité et il y a un enjeu
surtout pour moi
selon vous la pièce est elle dans quelle
main dans la main gauche ou dans la main
droite dans la droite
vous vous êtes sûr de vous vous ne
voulez pas la main gauche plutôt bon
vous avez dit la droite
alors je vais pouvoir poursuivre mon
intervention mais mais êtes vous sûr
d'avoir eu tous les éléments pour bien
décider
comment notre esprit rationnel réagi
face à une prise de décision
et pourquoi parfois lorsque nous
décidons nous nous trompons tout en
étant persuadé d'avoir raison
dans un instant je vais induire votre
esprit en erreur je vais vous tromper
mais je vous assure que vous garderez le
sourire et l'objectif sera d'en tirer
quelques clés pour améliorer nos prises
de décision je vais tous vous demander
de fermer les yeux un instant fermi tous
les yeux un instant
oui monsieur vous pouvez fermer les yeux
je vous en prie faites moi confiance
fermez les yeux un instant et imaginer
devant vous un écran blanc et sur cet
écran blanc imaginez un dessin simple
quelque chose que vous pourriez
reproduire ou d'écrire facilement
visualiser le dessin sur l'écran et une
fois que vous avez terminé
vous pouvez ouvrir les yeux à présent je
vais tous vous demander de vous lever
levez vous levez vous lever vous et
restez où vous êtes
pensez à votre dessin les spectateurs
qui pensent à une fleur une forme
géométrique ou une maison
asseyez-vous les participants qu'ils
pensent un bonhomme un visage ou un
moyen de transport
asseyez-vous les spectateurs qui pense à
un arbre un animal un soleil ou un nuage
asseyez vous vous remarquerez comment en
trois coups nous avons réussi à deviner
90% des dessins ici présents 1
d'après ce test psychologique parce que
bien sûr c'était un test psychologique
les spectateurs qui sont assis ont un
raisonnement logique et normal
[Applaudissements]
non je vous rassure j'ai fait ça
uniquement pour tenter quelque chose
avec les 5% restants regardons par ici
regardons par l'un par ici ou par l'un
kylie kylie votre prénom dites moi alors
alors vous serez parfaite pour cela je
vous en prie faites le tour et venez me
rejoindre sur scène on peut vous
applaudir valait alors je vous en prie
on est par ici prenez les escaliers
alors en plus du dessin que vous avez à
l'esprit alors je vais également vous
demander de penser à un prénom au prénom
de quelqu'un que vous aimez que vous
appréciez vous avez son son prénom en
tête
oui parfait alors pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de triche entre nous placez vous ici je
vous en prie et je vous confie un cahier
et un crayon écrivait le prénom en
lettres capitales ici et fait le dessin
juste en dessous alors je ferme les yeux
assurez-vous que personne ne vous
regarde ni en eau ni sur les côtés ni
derrière pas de caméra non plus braqués
sur le cahier et une fois que vous avez
terminé alors d'écrire le prénom en
lettres capitales et de faire le descend
en dessous
fermez le cahier posé le cahier le
crayon sur le tabouret sur lequel vous
êtes assise et venez me rejoindre
vous y êtes où il fermait le cahier est
posée le cahier sur le tabouret vous
êtes parfait alors nous allons commencer
par le prénom ne bougez pas je vais vous
demander dans un instant de penser je
dirais à la première lettre
la première lettre du prénom alors
regardez moi un instant dans les su
placer vos bras le long du corps c'est
parfait pensez à la première lettre du
prénom a b c d e f g h i j k l abysse
c'est un a ou un b
la première lettre est un as ou un b oui
c'est un as très bien et essayons avec
une une autre lettre au milieu du prénom
pensait masculin au féminin masculin au
féminin
mais c'est un prénom féminin oui très
bien c'est un prénom féminin
à nouveau a b c d e f g h i j klm n
aupeo clignement des yeux au niveau de
haine c'est un n rester avec moi je vous
en prie beaucoup
vous pensiez au n est ce pas parfait je
ne suis pas sûr si ça ne marche pas nous
nous référons vous m'avez dit anne-laure
votre prénom
alors vous le promet t on ne se connaît
pas en espagne et vous n'êtes pas
complice ça n'est ce pas bien à haute
voix alors
pourriez vous annoncer que tout le monde
vous entendent bien jusqu'au fond le
prénom de la personne à laquelle vous
pensiez bravo à nord non mais c'est trop
alors est-ce que vous avez également le
décès en tête
vous l'avez parfait prenez ce papier ce
crayon et je vais également prendre un
papier et un crayon ici alors comme ceci
nous allons nous placer d'eau contre
d'eau vous allez vous placer face aux
coulisses comme ceux ci et d'eau contre
dos alors si vous deviez faire le dessin
que vous avez en tête vous le feriez
dans ce sens anne laure ou dans ce sens
dans ce sens parfait alors à mon top
départ vraiment à mon top alors vous
faites le dessin est ce que vous êtes
prête top
vous avez fini moi aussi alors montré à
tout le monde ce que vous avez fait
c'est un verre ou un vase inverse
inverse est inverse que vous aviez à
l'esprit le mien est un peu différent
mais c'est un verre aussi on peut vous
applaudir je vous en prie merci anne
laure vous avez été formidables
vous pouvez regagner votre place je vous
en prie je vous en prie arrêtons nous un
instant sur ce que nous venons de vivre
je voudrais levé un coin du voile sur
cette expérience de mentalisme et
évoquer avec vous certains pièges de la
pensée que j'utilise pour vous
surprendre pour vous étonner mais qui
peuvent fausser notre jugement lors
d'une prise de décision
que s'est-il passé pendant ces quelques
minutes
et bien je vous ai tout d'abord demandé
de penser à un dessin et nous nous
sommes aperçus que 90% d'entre nous
penser aux mêmes desseins pourquoi cela
est bien notre esprit a mis en oeuvre
inconsciemment ce qu'on appelle un
cadrage serré
le cadrage serré c'est lorsque nous
réduisons naturellement nos possibilités
de choix est la cause du cadrage serré
et bien c'est le fait que notre cerveau
simplifie en permanence il doit
simplifier et bien tout simplement pour
gérer la complexité du quotidien et
c'est ce mécanisme qui explique que si
je vous demande de penser à un dessin et
bien votre esprit va mobiliser
rapidement des images simples et
familière alors l'avantagent c'est que
votre cerveau n'est pas pris au dépourvu
le désavantage c'est qu'il reste dans
une zone de confort et réduit nos
possibilités de choix et lors d'une
prise de décision et bien le cadrage
serré il est particulièrement insidieux
parce qu'ils conditionnent la question
sur laquelle on répond on le repère
lorsque la décision repose sur un choix
binaire
par exemple est-ce que je dois quitter
mon job actuel pour être plus épanouie
au lieu de se demander comment être plus
épanouie ou bien un entrepreneur qui se
demandent est-ce qu'il faut que je
baisse le prix de mes produits pour
faire face à la concurrence
au lieu de se demander quels sont les
paramètres sur lesquels jouer pour
contrer la concurrence
le cadrage serré c'est le premier
automatismes de la pensée dont il faut
se méfier le second piège que j'ai
utilisé lors de la séquence de
mentalisme
si ce qu'on appelle les fausses
corrélation les fausses corrélation
c'est quoi et bien c'est notre capacité
à créer des liens de cause à effet entre
des éléments qui ont peu en commun pour
créer du sens et nous convaincre
par exemple tout à l'heure lorsque j'ai
deviné le prénom pensé par la
spectatrice
eh bien vous avez cherché une
explication rationnelle et vous avez
observé que je récitais les lettres de
l'alphabet en observant la spectatrice
et en déduisant certaines lettres du
prénom et votre hypothèse
ça a été que je me servais des réactions
non verbal de la spectatrice pourront
déduire le prénom est bien cette
hypothèse est fausse c'est une fausse
corrélation un fou lien logique que j'ai
placé à ce moment de l'expérience pour
en protéger le véritable secret et ce
secret et bien je peux pas vous le
révéler
mais ce qu'il faut retenir ici c'est que
les fausses corrélation c'est un piège
dans lequel nous tombons fréquemment
vous avez par exemple l'intuition d'une
tendance nouvelle qui peut transformer
radicalement votre métier est bien votre
inconscient va avoir tendance à aller
chercher les faits qui vont confirmer
cette intuition les signaux contraires
ou les contre arguments seront
naturellement écartés ou considérés
comme des cas particuliers ou des
exceptions parce que notre inconscient
veut valider ce que nous voulions
prouver par avance en plus du cadrage
serré et des fausses corrélation
j'aimerais mentionner un dernier piège
de la pensée qui peut nous jouer des
tours
lors d'une prise de décision c'est
l'excès d'informations souvent lorsqu'on
regarde un spectacle de mentalisme ou
d'illusionnisme la première réflexion
qui nous vient à l'esprit c'est je ne
comprends pas ce qui se passe pas parce
qu'il me manque d information il y a des
choses ici qui sont utilisés que je ne
connais pas si je regardais le le
spectacle depuis les coulisses je
comprendrais ce qui se passe en fait
celle inverse
vous avez devant vous tout à l'heure
tous les éléments toutes les
informations pour comprendre
l'expérience de mentalisme c'est juste
que votre esprit n'a pas su distinguer
les informations importantes de celle
qui était superflu et lors d'une prise
de décision ça arrive fréquemment on
pense qu'il nous faut un supplément
d'information pour bien décidée alors
par exemple on va commander un énième
rapport
on va repousser l'échéance de la
décision pour collecter davantage de
données alors que souvent toutes les
informations sont là pour prendre une
décision pertinente
il faut juste pouvoir distinguer les
informations les plus utiles cadrages
serrés fausse corrélation ex et
d'information ce sont ces trois pièges
de la pensée dont il faut se méfier lors
d'une prise de décision
finalement lorsqu'on décide l'un des
plus grands dangers
ce n'est pas le risque ce n'est pas
l'incertitude
c'est le décideur lui même et sa
rationalité qui peut lui jouer des tours
alors une façon de minimiser ces pièges
de la pensée est bien c'est de poser un
regard sur soi d'avoir conscience de son
propre mode de raisonnement
lors d'une prise de décision et il y à
quelques outils simples mais efficaces
qui sont évoqués dans la littérature sur
le sujet que je voudrais partager avec
vous le premier outil
eh bien il permet d'éviter le cadrage
serré en multipliant les options et en
utilisant les questions alternative
on l'a vu tout à l'heure le cadrage
serré on le repère lorsque la décision
repose sur un dilemme
par exemple est-ce que je dois accepter
ce poste qu'on me propose à l'étranger
pour faire évoluer ma carrière est bien
une façon d'en sortir c'est de poser la
question alternative suivante si on ne
me proposait pas ce poste à l'étranger
et que je souhaitais faire évoluer ma
carrière qu'est ce que je pourrais faire
par moi-même pour le réaliser et ça
permet de stimuler l'imagination et
rapidement de trouver d'autres options
et d'éviter de se laisser enfermer dans
un choix binaire
alors une fois qu'on a plusieurs options
on peut avoir l'intuition qu'une option
est plus pertinente que les autres et
lun on court le risque de tomber dans le
piège des fausses corrélation qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure
eh bien il ya un outil qui permet
d'éviter cela c'est l'avocat de l'ange
se faire l'avocat de l'ange
c'est ce faire inverse de l'avocat du
diable en se posant la question et si
l'option que nous aimons le moins qui
nous semble la moins crédible était en
fait la plus pertinente
quelles sont les données quelles sont
les informations qui nous le prouverai
et l'avocat lange
nous permet de prendre du recul par
rapport à nos convictions et nos
intuitions et une fois qu'on a fait
l'avocat de l'ange est bien l'enjeu
c'est de ne pas tomber dans l'excès
d'information en prenant de la hauteur
par rapport aux informations et aux
données collectées et pour cela il y a
un outil que j'aime bien qui s'appelle
le 10 10 10 le 10 10 10
c'est un outil qui permet de se projeter
de dans l'avenir et de penser la
décision en fonction de trois échéances
chronologique
qu'en pensera ton dans dix minutes qu'en
pensera ton dans dix mois
qu'en pensera ton dans dix ans et ce
changement de perspective
eh bien il permet de mettre de côté
pendant un instant les faits les
informations pour se concentrer sur nos
priorités essentielles et je voudrais
mentionner une dernière chose vous avez
remarqué comment tout à l'heure 90%
d'entre nous penser aux mêmes desseins
mais chacun réfléchisse et seul
si vous aviez réfléchi collectivement
vous auriez probablement abouti à des
dessins différents et certainement plus
originaux les outils que je viens
d'évoquer l'un et bien ils sont d'autant
plus efficaces s'ils sont réalisés
collectivement et en équipe
au fond les pièges de la pensée on ne
peut pas y échapper
on peut seulement savoir qu'ils existent
et ont minimisé les conséquences en les
contournant alors quand vous prendrez
une décision
pensez à l'illusionniste qui est en vous
et qui peut vous jouer des tours vous
connaissez à présent ces trucs les
pièges qu'ils utilisent
n'oubliez pas de les déjouer pour mieux
décider
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]